[Music]
and welcome back to another awesome
episode of the careful boys where we are
super and extremely careful and today i
think we could be more careful we
probably could but we have jason cheney
in the building today
what's up dog hey thank you so much for
having me man i
haven't been here in a long time yeah
dude thank you you're welcome man i'm
always i'm always excited to have guests
on my show here
but uh our weather man bart why don't
you take it away bart yeah so i have a
couple questions two of them that's not
weather no it's not weather at all uh
the first one is like what got you into
stand-up comedy because i know like a
lot of people have their own personal
story and the second one is i found out
that you've been in a comedy boxing
match before and i want to know about
that let's get to the first one first
okay thank you for your question bart
you're very welcome um most polite man
i got into stand up because uh why are
you making a face like that oh i'm
trying to understand sorry that's just
the steps
you're making our guests feel good hide
your face man wait five more minutes and
he'll throw you off like this
thank you very comfortable i feel very
hard for that i got to stand up because
i really just wanted to express myself
like growing up i didn't move in with my
parents until fifth grade and but i was
really thankful that my grandmother
raised me yeah i didn't know okay you
know what i didn't know that's a thing
that's why i'm saying it now because i
started to see a therapist during the
pandemic when i was 29 years old i don't
know why i'm pointing like this but i
feel like i wanted to talk to everybody
hey give me one of these i wanted to
talk to everybody and also
for the viewers at home uh
but i didn't know
you grew up with your grandma yeah
yeah grandma grandpa my uncle and my
aunt but um but when i was 29 see a
therapist
uh she she was like hey you know ask me
about my background
and
also
she she so i was telling him yeah and i
moved in with my parents until fifth
grade and then she's like what and i was
like yeah you know whatever and she's
like probably not and then so we
i like your therapist
i don't like how she's making up
problems for you that's what i'm saying
that's a normal asian [ __ ] story i
was so happy we were all we were all
raised by grandparents i was happy until
i saw my thing is your their what what
ethnicity is the therapist what what uh
see that that's that's that's a that's a
big deal but you know what i love her
though she's great you fell in love in a
sexual way
just to be clear it's sexual that's not
ethical bro
uh
no and then uh
i wanted to do stand-up because i i
think asian culture they it's just you
know we you guys talked about it i'm
sure plenty of times just you don't ask
questions just do what you're told all
the time and i didn't ever oh my when i
went to college
uh miramar college uh they had critical
thinking with it she already checked out
i feel like no i like critical thinking
that was one of my favorite classes
super checked in you got to be able to
read him the right way
no because he was wearing a hat looking
over there at the dinosaur and i was
like jill's trick hey don't check out
dude
no no don't even guess because you're
not going to guess it right
that's just that's just the room that's
just continuing not even playing
checkers dude he's playing chess
um
no but yeah and after yeah after i uh i
forgot what was the same thing
you checked out
[Laughter]
i
uh yeah and i didn't know what critical
thinking was because we don't exist it
doesn't exist in asian people well at
least to me like specifically because
they're like you know critical thing you
have to think for yourself and i was
like i don't even know just tell me what
you want and then
memorize it tell me what you want me to
say tell me what i needed to do but
critically think for yourself i remember
this is recent too that i was like oh
maybe that's the thing and then from
there i just want to express myself and
i bombed super hard um
i have a question how much
[Applause]
oh how about you i need this blessing
i like i like i like what you observe
because i always told myself the reason
why asians are not the superior race
is because they're hard drives not
processors what i mean by that is they
just download everything exactly but
they don't know how to process right and
it's because critical thinking does not
exist in the culture the way that it
does in western culture because the the
the whole like
philosophy behind it you know like
western philosophy argument debate
thinking
you know coming down with the the
scientific method like all that stuff it
they teach it in asia but not in the
house
so we don't it's not like um you don't
have discussions you have you just have
orders orders and you obey but you know
what i feel like asians
they process the processors are five
percent and i think uh western culture
is like you know a 50 60 more percentage
because i feel like
the
hard drives are most of the people and i
think the five percent give it to the
most of the people that's why china's so
strong because they have the smartest
people but only a small amount but then
they make the rest of the people be
a process they're a terabyte in america
i like i said slit processors
what was he gonna say what was the word
of course but yeah i wanted to express
myself but slave slave is one syllable
processor
i can't say it
how are you able to like
especially being like a good asian right
where you're like well i wasn't i was
like i was the worst in class every were
you a troublemaker yeah i was i was but
because i just want to have a good time
and i was kicked out of class like every
class and i was like spanked bart's
eyebrows like oh fellow troublemaker i
see he goes what would you do you guys
are like taiwanese troublemakers well
like when you when you bombed what kept
you
going because that's all even when the
first i'd like for the first i would i
sucked so bad yeah the first two years
but i just wanted to say what i think
just i just want to have a good time
regardless of what was funny or not but
but it still hurt a lot though
it hurt a lot but not more than not be
able to say the thing but the way i
started was really like um
because i was so sad like i would
literally told myself like if i'm going
to dude when i was in um fifth
fifth grade or fourth grade i told my
grandma that man i want to kill myself i
remember this i told my grandma you were
suicidal at fifth grade yeah
no but yeah so i told my grandma like
hey i think i'm gonna kill myself right
and then i remember my grandma i was
sitting on on this bed and then
my dad walked in and then my grandma
told my dad and then my dad's like he's
not brave enough
and it just
i remember that really specifically but
um like my son is a beach
exactly but so so when i before i
started stand-up um i wanted to do three
things i uh which is really a really
lame thing it was like
white water rafting which i haven't done
yet let's go
i want to do that too you want to do it
i'll do it but have you done it though
no but i'm down why is that lame that
seems so fun people said it's really
them david david david [ __ ] said it
was lame i told him
everything is lame have you even done
you know why he says that it's because
he's scared yeah he doesn't like heights
he doesn't like he doesn't like anything
yeah [ __ ] you david that's why he's like
that's scary but i didn't know that but
he made me feel bad just tell him
to get into a white water after you have
to climb up a ladder and then it'll
[ __ ] shut up roasting someone's
bucket list is probably the meanest
thing you could do i know okay what's
number two so yeah so i had three i was
like if i'm going to die these are the
three things so why water everything and
then get my motorcycles licensed hey
that's cool
is that cool do you want to learn how to
ride a motorcycle i could teach you i do
yeah but the thing i don't have a
license but i just
just do a basic writer's course you can
get it in a weekend yeah so you can't
get in a week it only costs 250 bucks i
got mine you can get in one weekend i
don't even have a motorcycle anymore
let's start with your road though
i had a scooter that's a scooter bro not
a motorcycle you don't even have a
license full you're gonna yeah but i had
a motorcycle hey bring out the hat you
need more tips
what's the third thing the third thing
was stand up and then so i passed my
written test on my motorcycle
and uh before the road you know the
class i did stand up and right when i
did it i was like oh man i i have to do
this and then i just kept doing it and
didn't do the other things and i
haven't stopped what was the first time
where was it how did you feel like did
you prepare or no i just wanted to
because it just seemed super fun oh no i
i we went to like me and my wife went to
an open mic
and i was like because the only stand-up
comedy show that i've ever seen live was
kevin hart's
like arena thing yeah and i was like oh
my god this is the best and i went to
like a comedy club which i've never have
because asian culture
people don't really go to stand-up
comedy it's not a thing like why would
karaoke go yeah karaoke is way more fun
you could do that at home and stuff and
people don't shame you know but um
when to open my console's comedy hold at
that point joe rogan was blowing up and
he will go there and lie to him like oh
my god i want to do an open mic and then
i went and you have to pay five dollars
i'm like i'm not doing this stupid thing
so i was like no no i'm just gonna watch
and then i go and then there's like five
people at the thing and they were
calling people's names and they're like
jason
uh van glass or whatever or stein right
and then i was like what i can't believe
that there's a jason and i was like me
and then he was like
are you jason stein
and i was like no but i'm jason
and then he was like all right and then
so that's how i went out for the first
time and i bought what
you didn't even have nothing prepared
you just stand up just that sounds
scarier than [ __ ] riding a motorcycle
what you just freestyled it you didn't
have any when i was sitting down i was
like what do i want to talk about and
then
um i i wanted to talk about this fish
tank
what was the first tell us tell us the
bit tell us it's a stupid bit well yes
what did you just tell us about the fish
tank already bombed there you can't bomb
here again give us your worst material
it's probably going to be funnier no
it's not it's so bad that it's not funny
it's the thing it's just like we have a
bar try us so what'd you start
a fish tank sounds pretty funny would
you
how did you like what did you lead with
i just i just went up and i was like man
this is awesome everybody
did you did you start out with what's
the deal with fish tanks
that was yeah that was way better than
what i said for sure but i i just went
and i was just like uh
i i think that i just rift yeah but yeah
and then i did a fish i was just really
cool that how fish they turn at the same
time
he already won them over dude that's
[ __ ] awesome but the thing is like
how how he's not even telling the joker
no but that there's no joke but there's
no i don't even have a punch line yeah i
don't even have a punchline but
you're making fun of me you're doing
this and you [ __ ] i'm not me you
don't know how fish turn at the same
time
they turn at the exact same time is the
thing how do they do it all of them
not one or two all of them they all go
[Laughter]
how did they turn in vietnamese and then
when he said that
everyone was just like it's just
crickets like
oh yeah did people laugh there's also
five people in the [ __ ] crowd you
know okay there was like six please
there was that but i one comic he was
like
haha like that yeah that was me probably
it was you and i really appreciate it
that kept me going
that's why i'm here it's your boy
was your wife there too the whole time
no no no that would have been fun
you [ __ ] suck you don't know nothing
about fish and then when you see when
they gave you the light were you like oh
thank god i'm getting off stage or
it's like whatever thing it was just
like okay cool it was like i think like
four or five minutes it was really long
to me it was yeah at the time it was
like super super long but i had a good
time how did you know that you bombed
the way you felt or the way that people
treated you
both
[Laughter]
you ruined jason stein's reputation yeah
jason stein's they're like man that
jason stein guys
this fish tank [ __ ] what was that dude
he's on like a no-fly list for all come
come you just ruined it for him but you
know what there is a comedian after he's
like hey man that was funny and then
i was like yeah
and then i just
kept doing it yeah so when when did you
go oh i actually want to do this for a
job
i don't think ev it's i think it's like
a
everyday thing every day i have to
convince myself like hey this might
not it might just be like this forever
but i would rather do this every day i'm
like well i don't want to do radio shack
or
uh
i don't even know if it's radio shack is
still there bro you're either do what
you love or go on a radio show your
career outlived radio shows i know i
wanna do radio shack i don't wanna do
circuits my bar's super low
that's pretty good i don't want best buy
either i like
naming stores that are all closed down i
like that your bar's that low
yeah how about ethan allen we got a
special relationship with ethan allen
they're still in business who's ethan
allen it's a furniture store it's like
the new ring one of the most hospitable
furniture
that bart got his ass beaten can i
almost got his ass say it saved me what
how my dad was beating my ass in a
parking lot of ethan allen and then i
was uh i ran away
because i don't want to get my ass beat
and there's the ethanol it's the
furniture store so i went inside and i
hid in one of the cabinets
he hid in the cabinet and then they
saved me
yeah and then i asked a
white lady savior to save me for my evil
asian death but he still beats your ass
after though no no my parents are
divorced yeah but he still beat your ass
after when he found you well he can't
see me for another week he can only see
me on tuesdays so he's very smart he's
very smart so he hid in the ethan allen
till wednesday
he ate the cabinet
this is surviving there can i can i ask
what uh what your therapist said was a
bad thing about you moving in with your
parents later what do you probably just
like a
abandonment but we we haven't explored
that because there was another thing
that we wanted to talk about but she was
like oh that's the thing do you feel
comfortable exploring that right now so
she thinks you had abandonment issues
like that you didn't know about i i
don't know but it seems like i don't
know but what do you assume
push push push it down yeah and forget
it at all because that's all we do as
asian or people who beat your ass
everything you just go yeah this is
this is just going yeah but and it's
like normal both sides push it down my
dad used to [ __ ] me up and i called him
out on it and he says i didn't do that
dude dude i have this new [ __ ]
they they're the best at gaslighting
yeah did your dad gaslight your ass too
but i don't even know that it's like
it's a thing until recently people say
gaslighting i don't even know what that
is i just found out i have to google it
i have to read words i have to have to
read words i don't know what gaslighting
i like
that sounds so stupid it's so dumb yeah
but you that go are you a [ __ ] and i'm
like maybe and then you just try not to
be a [ __ ] your whole life
and then now they're like no that's bad
i'm like oh it's bad
so what did your therapist say when you
were like yeah i told my grandma that i
want to kill myself my dad you know what
that part
that this was the first time that i ever
said it out loud yeah two people because
i just
because i just thought that like
a couple couple months watch out you're
gaslighting yourself you remembered it
what exactly was happening at that age
that you were like [ __ ] this life like
what was going on i just i don't know
it's just because i was bad at
everything all the time it's just i was
failing school everything and then i was
getting
bullied
where did my
and i was running away it was taiwan
yeah when did you come to america again
eighth grade oh eight i loved it yeah it
was the best was it was it better when
you came here of course it's so nice and
i was like uh smoking a little weed
where what city it was in carlsbad i
went straight into uh you know straight
to the kingdom of glory carlsbad yeah i
went to army and navy academy i went to
that school no you didn't i did carlsbad
are you serious yeah are you in his
[ __ ] unit dude no way dude no okay
you go there's a there's a central quad
in grass right this the buildings is
shaping clean holes queen hall yeah and
in the back there's there's a beach yeah
yeah and then there's a child hall right
here or a mess hall right here oh
yeah and then there's uh there is rooms
facing the street that during that time
i don't know during your time in our
time we would have drug dealers pull up
and then you can meet them right on the
street and that's how the people got the
drugs is that how you did it too yeah
but not they wouldn't they weren't doing
it like that at the end people just
bring it in on the weekends
and then if you get in trouble you got
to walk those [ __ ] squares or
something i never got to go out i walk
the square every day yeah me too every
day i walk this way by myself i was like
yes this is the best yeah
dude that's [ __ ] great i never met
anyone that went to that school were you
in trouble is that why they sent you you
guys are both talented troublemakers
that [ __ ] your parents just wanted
you to just get disciplined sure that's
one two taiwanese troublemakers dude
troublemakers have you met anyone else
that went to a a not outside but i kept
in touch with some and they're really
nice they're
good guys what do you know holy [ __ ]
that's like when we found out we went to
the same spot i know but i came alone
though did you
sorry i just had to flex a little bit
what do you mean um did you come along
with your family or did you come alone
did you come with your family or come
along
because you oh no you were born in
america so yeah i got i got sent there
because i got kicked out of two other
high schools already so i got sent there
oh god he's flexing that he came to
america by himself oh that's that is a
that's a good flex though i did have
parents they sent me there they loved
you no yeah yeah
[Laughter]
you went there the whole time two and a
half no i wanted to graduate but then
two and after two and a half years i
went to a public school
in uh in san diego westview and i love
that oh you went to west view yeah
but only for last year
you went to osu no you didn't do
it
go ahead and name anything i know
someone in your zone do you like pudding
no pudding
someone do a bill of coffee what a crazy
that's interesting
it's such a weird school i've never met
anyone that went there well you just
keep on saying it but you have friends
that is in your class that still you
still know but nobody random like this
that's pretty crazy only two taiwanese
troublemakers
the only people that i know that i
remember from that school was 11 of us
got expelled at the same time that's
that's a that's a lot but what
is it is it drugs or is it drugs related
and we're running a uh
uh like a
that's a nice way of saying organized
crime no we're
and then they caught all 11 of us and
this all of us got kicked out a drug
racket
how long did you go there for
five months oh got sent there oh he's
laughing at you i got sent there he's
laughing i didn't even finish a semester
he goes that's push wait why didn't you
finish the semester because the [ __ ]
they found out about our
our [ __ ] pass around thing about uh
so you kept doing something
but what was the thing what was the drug
just like ecstasy and weed it's funny
that it's a bunch of military boys doing
ecstasy together
that's just funny
well it's not in the military but
they're high school kids
everyone's in high school it's a
boarding school and then you end up
sleeping there so you don't have [ __ ] to
do so you never got you never got
bullied there i did and then but we all
like after it was fun we threw piss on
each other jerk off on each other's
pillows and stuff
and i was showing my friend my
was a good penis
it looks like you're reminiscing as
you're saying i like how it's a bunch of
navy boys that are doing ecstasy and
massaging each other and coming on each
other's pillows it was a good time it
could be gay i'm saying it would be fun
if it was gay too gay hadn't been
invented yet at that time it was
definitely gay guys but it was a good
time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you